hello welcome to this video playing
Frank ed yeah that's someone I know so
let's see what we get here turn a clock
made of mine so I'm playing something
different here prize that you went t45
hmm they already see 5 yeah ok let's
just play C 3 keep it simple what idea
is to delay the and yeah to the lane
idea three so that this kind of thing as
possible even though here if it takes on
d4 it's not in bad shape i thinkin I rke
goes for Bishop to a 6 mm
tough to prevent and what's the idea
with the delaying that that night be 8
mm okay a very good idea
now I cannot do much here those trades
helped him a bit too organized but i can
try to smuggle shoot 4g for but ok here
we go let me take that one I see Scott
queenside play possible Koontz I play
c4b five things like that ok well if you
go see for I go in for Queen Avery's
play to play Knight f3 next maybe 95 or
still g4 ok if I he cannot play anyway I
was a bit a bit of a superfluous move
here ok so
c5 now possible or 95 then I cannot
really do much them yeah if five if you
get city five nothing happens here ever
but I don't see anything great I mean I
can try I can try this key five like d
takes d5 ft x + f5 it's probably be
dicey but get some fight going maybe
yeah maybe 95 96 as a possible idea now
also see for us sometimes c4d for then i
get the square e for for my night which
is not I know decisive or so with
something
hmm plays it plays it anyway just like
that okay
canta maybe he might sacrifice the
exchange them check
Jack hmm can you sacrifice the exchange
if not I'm just grabbing deform I mean
looks like a porn
nope doesn't do it check anyway I have
to take it and not going to get more all
of this than this porn
yeah just just a flat porn and jack my
king is a little bit more active yeah
for TM
yeah i think i'm going for activity here
cannot play a passive move like rook t2
and I can but I don't want to
okay so i can check here then it goes to
f6 kinky five he has the check they
unfortunately rookie to check and this
is not helping me a lot hmm
hey that's probably enough here for him
to hold the draw pretty sure yeah it's
active enough check check
again yes got the chick I'm going for
activity here if he goes group here I
check and go King e5 check I can check
me from the back time morning probably
the whole time and I have no check good
way I like that check check check check
check if six is a draw oh I can do that
rah our third game drawn yeah let's just
do that draw he get the phone he was
active enough them he was active enough
maybe I can improve somewhere here this
here King and King up must be right and
maybe he am maybe I can improve here but
he's got that Roxy to counterclaim
probably taking us better
check something like that but the
drawing majha is pretty high here pretty
high yeah I blackboard r all this I
guess I don't see myself winning this
yeah okay I got very little down check
yeah I mean it got so could've played
here yeah maybe g5 is an idea yeah there
was some interesting points they are on
the Kings side jack jessee's this is
leading to an advantage he doesn't
cannot sacrifice the exchange there can
I can I prove here maybe taking later or
when I don't think so check check this
is an idea
I went to hear and if i go here tix i
can take with the rook and here i have
this idea now in some cases hmm yeah
it's still probably a draw and still
probably draw okay well thanks for
watching